[Música]
hola y sean todos bienvenidos a 5
minutos con como cada mes tenemos el
placer de vivir de cerca con ustedes la
misión de tomates que a bordo de la
estación espacial internacional el
astronauta francés y su tripulación
estarán seis meses en órbita alrededor
de la tierra la sesión espacial
internacional se amplía y a pesar de
tener más de 20 años se les siguen
haciendo mejoras tras los nuevos paneles
solares de los que nos habló toma pues
que el mes pasado esta vez un nuevo
módulo se incorporó a la estación
hablamos del mlm nam khao módulo
científico ruso que despegó el 21 de
julio desde el cosmódromo de baikonur en
kazajistán a bordo del cohete ruso
protón ahora nauta forma parte de la
estructura de la estación espacial
internacional e incluso es el módulo más
imponente con sus 20 toneladas y más de
70 metros cúbicos de volumen en el
interior
aquí una visita guiada con tomates que
la semana pasada también recibimos una
nuevo módulo a bordo de la estación
espacial lo cual es usual así que nos
alegramos de estar a bordo cuando llegó
sustituyó al antiguo módulo ruso que
estuvo allí durante 20 años y se llama
mlm tuvimos algunos percances tras este
acoplamiento porque lastimosamente
cuando lo integramos a los sistemas de
la estación el mlm pensó que estaba
volando el único problema es que se
llevó la estación con él pudimos
arreglar la situación rápidamente pero
esto es el espacio a veces las cosas no
funcionan como lo esperamos pero tenemos
procedimientos para eso estamos
entrenados y todos estábamos listos voy
a mostrarles este módulo y vamos a la
parte trasera de la estación al lado
ruso vamos
[Música]
aquí está abajo hacia la tierra el
módulo más reciente de la estación
espacial
al abrir la esclusa cuando tenemos un
módulo que viene del espacio siempre
huele un poco a caliente poco a quemado
como a bloqueador solar es el ciclo
térmico la exposición al calor del sol
lo que crea este olor especial y hoy
volvemos a tenerlo aquí podemos ver que
el pasillo central estaba lleno de
equipos nuestros colegas rusos ya
empezaron a ordenarlo todo a moverlo
todo pero aún falta así que tendremos
que tener cuidado bajaremos al fondo de
este módulo
y de aquí a la derecha tenemos un nuevo
baño y a bordo de la estación espacial
internacional este será nuestro tercer
baño parece ser una pequeñez pero es
algo en lo que se debe pensar cuando se
está en el espacio y con el aumento de
la cantidad de miembros de la
tripulación a bordo de la estación
espacial
hubo que encontrar soluciones esta es
una de ellas pasamos de tres astronautas
a seis a siete y pronto tal vez incluso
habrá más muchos de los equipos aquí son
equipos científicos y equipos de
investigación a ambos lados también
tendremos una sala de control para el
brazo robótico europeo que se encuentra
fuera de mlm esta sala de control va a
estar aquí que aún no está terminada
aquí vemos las siglas aérea que
significa european robótica es un brazo
robótico que es el equivalente más
simple de lo que hay en el otro lado de
los brazos que hay al otro lado de la
estación construido y diseñado en europa
y llegó a bordo con este módulo como
pueden verlo estamos en plena
instalación haciendo arreglos
y si
estás una estación que los rusos llaman
k yuta la cabina para un miembro de la
tripulación una estructura rígida con
todas las comodidades modernas en el
interior y una pequeña ventana para
mirar por ahí
por el momento está ocupado almacenando
cosas
y luego aquí abajo hay una segunda parte
de mlm es un módulo que tiene una forma
bastante redonda que se utilizará para
acoplar otros módulos tendremos una
esclusa aquí que nos permitirá sacar los
experimentos al exterior de mlm
del lado ruso del también tenemos una
nueva ventana que por el momento está
cerrada pero que se puede abrir se
parece al lente de una cámara es
bastante amplia bastante grande y tiene
una vista de 45 grados hacia la tierra
por lo que será un gran lugar para
observar la tierra una vez que la
hayamos abierto lamentablemente esto
todavía no está programado eso es todo
por primera vez en exclusiva un
recorrido por el módulo mlm y no olviden
que cada mes toda vez que nos entregará
detalles sólo aquí en france 24 gracias
y los invitamos a seguir con nuestra
programación
[Música]